- When preparing for
consulting interviews,
people focus so much on the case study
part of the interview,
but other parts such as
the experience interviews
are often overlooked by candidates
and are not properly prepared,
and this can really be a deal breaker
for your consulting application.
Today, we are going to talk about
how you pass interviews at
management consulting firms,
so it doesn't matter if you want to apply
to an MBB firm or a big
four consulting firm.
This video has you covered.
Hi guys, my name is
Heinrich Rusche and come
to another coffee break here
on my channel Firm Learning.
On my channel, I want to
help you to become successful
in the first years of your career,
so it doesn't matter if
you're working in consulting
and investment banking or
in a corporate context.
I am here to help you.
As always, if you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this
channel for weekly videos of me.
And if you want to see even more content,
I also have an Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning,
so follow me on my Instagram as well
to see even more content from me.
Since I made this channel,
many of you have approached me
and asked me to talk about
the interview process
of management consulting firms.
What does it take to
pass these interviews?
How exactly are these
interviews structured,
and what are my tips and tricks
to help you get the job that you want.
And I'm really passionate about this topic
because the great thing
for you as a candidate
is that it doesn't matter what
consulting firm you apply to,
the key building blocks of the
interview that you will face
are pretty similar among
all of the firms out there.
So and of course there are
differences among these firms.
If you understand these
basic building blocks
that consulting interviews are made of,
then you will be really well set
for all of these interviews to come.
And the truth is in the end,
there are three of these building blocks.
Three building blocks
that most of these consulting
interviews consist of.
The first is the CV review part,
so an interview section
where the interviewer
talks to you about your CV.
The second is the experience interview
where the interviewer deep dives with you
into specific situations,
specific experiences
that you had in the past,
and the third is the case study interview.
This is the section where the interviewer
discusses with you a real business problem
and wants to understand
how you would handle
these kinds of problems as a candidate,
because of course this would be the task
that you are facing as a consultant.
Beyond then, there are some
other interview types as well
that some of the firms use,
but these more exotic
components are not the focus
of this video because today I
really want to drill it down
to the basics to help you
understand what you can expect
in these interviews.
So this video is structured
now in three parts.
First I'm going to talk about
the CV review interview,
second about the experience interview,
and third about the case study interview.
And guys, if you get these
three types interviews right,
then you will get that consulting job.
But before now we jump
into these three sections,
I have prepared something
really special for you.
I prepared a consulting
interview preparation checklist
that is a list of to dos that I believe
that you should do to prepare
yourself for these interviews.
It is structured along these
different types of interviews
and it also gives some tips
on these other more
exotic interview formats,
and from my perspective,
if you do exactly what I'm
writing in this checklist,
then the chances are pretty high
that you are well prepared
for the interviews to come.
So if you are interested
to get this checklist
that is completely free for you,
just look into the
video description below,
if there you'll subscribe to my newsletter
you will receive the
checklist as a download link,
and if you are already
subscribed to the newsletter,
of course, no problem,
just enter you email again
and you will get that checklist as well.
Let's start with section number one,
and this is the CV review interview,
and as with all the other
interview types to come,
this can either be an
independent interview session
with an interviewer only covering your CV,
but it can also be integrated in a session
where you both have a CV review section
and then later an experience interview
or later a case study or a
combination of all of the three,
so it's not necessarily the case
that you have a full interview
only discussing your CV,
but often it is also
integrated with other parts.
So what is the objective
of the CV review interview?
Why are consulting firms
doing this type of interview at all?
And the truth is, usually
the consulting firms
do not use this interview
section to sort out candidates
based on their CVs,
because this what already
happened in the pre-selection,
based on your written documents.
So the fact that you got
invited to the interview,
the fact that you are sitting in a room
with an interviewer of the
firm having this interview,
usually already means that
your CV was good enough.
The HR department considered your CVs
to meet all of the criteria to
get invited to the interview,
because otherwise you wouldn't be here.
So don't go into the
interview with the mindset
that now you need to prove yourself,
with the mindset that maybe
you are not good enough on the paper,
because usually you are.
But how do these firms use
this type of interview,
and it's usually used for two things.
First, it's just to build rapport,
and just to get to know you a bit better
on a personal level.
Often, the CV review interview
is rather done in the beginning,
and one of the earlier,
maybe even the first interview.
It is supposed to break the ice a bit
because of course as a candidate,
it is believed that you can
easily talk about yourself
and this puts you in less
stress than for instance,
doing a more complicated case study.
So just ease up a bit.
Be ready to build some
rapport with your interviewer.
Get to know each other and
just try to have a good time.
However, how some firms do
use the CV review section
is to drill down a bit,
to deep dive a bit on some of the things
that you write in your CV,
and they might especially do
that if they have some reason
to maybe doubt whether
some things that you write
are really accurate or not.
So be ready to receive
some critical questions,
maybe to explain a bit what you did
on certain elements on the CV
that you are writing about.
Be ready to go into some level of detail
to really give the interviewer the comfort
that of course everything that you wrote
is completely accurate
and completely correct.
One specific thing that
I want to encourage you
to prepare in advance for
this interview section
is to answer a question such as,
"Please walk me through your CV,"
or, "Please introduce yourself."
This is a question commonly asked
by the consultant in the beginning.
This should be a sign for
you to now give a short talk,
maybe around five minutes, about your CV,
about what you did in the past.
So this is something you can
really well prepare in advance
before the interview,
so just practice giving a
short, five minute presentation
about your background.
Go over the key stations in your life.
Both from a professional,
but also from an educational perspective.
What's important here is to not
get lost in the minor stuff.
Do not talk for three
minutes about an internship
that you did at high school,
or something like that.
Really focus on the things that matter.
Focus on the recent things
that are really important
and this already is an important
skill in business as well,
and especially as in consulting.
The interviewer wants to trust you
that if you sit in front of a client
and you're having such a
professional conversation,
that you can distinguish
the things that matter
from the things that do not matter.
So take this already
as a first little test
to make sure that you are well prepared,
because this is a question
that very likely will come
and this is something
that you can very easily
prepare at home.
The second interview section
that you should feel ready for
is the experience interview.
In the experience interview,
the interviewer will go into the details
of specific instances,
specific situations that
you've faced in the past
and how you handled, how
you solved these instances.
So what exactly are the
interviewers looking for here?
And well of course,
the criteria differ a
bit from firm by firm.
The criteria for the
McKinsey experience interview
are transparently
written on their website.
They're looking for personal impact,
for entrepreneurial drive,
for problem solving skills,
and for leadership.
So let's break that down.
What does it mean?
What are these people looking for?
So let's start with personal impact.
This is really about your achievements.
About the things that you
changed to the better.
Stories about personal impact
can both be from a business perspective
or from a social, community perspective,
where you created something
great for your community.
Entrepreneurial drive
can mean many things,
but to sum it up, for me in a nutshell
it means to leave a bit the normal path.
To not only do the things
that are expected from you,
but look for some creative
ways to solve problems,
to things that other
people have no done before.
Think of it out of the box.
This is what you should talk about
when you address this
entrepreneurship dimension.
Problem solving skills is about
your analytical abilities.
It is about cutting through complexity
of complex business challenges.
You can also talk about how you solved
a complex interpersonal
challenge that you had,
maybe also with some other
students in a university course
that you took, when you really
to make something happen.
Talk about how you can solve problems
that other people cannot solve.
And the last dimension is
your leadership ability.
While I agree that this
is a bit overlapping
with some of the other dimensions,
for me, leadership in this context
mainly means doing away with other people,
so maybe your own experience hire,
and already had some leadership
experience in the past
with extra teammates in the job,
or if you are fresh out of university,
maybe in university you were
a leading member of a club,
or maybe of a social organization
that you are a member
of the board of.
So here, talk about how you were able
to motivate other people,
to create a team and as a team
effort to get things done.
This, from my perspective, is leadership
and this is what will be
valued by consulting firms.
And again, these are
the McKinsey dimensions.
Other consulting firms
might have slightly different dimensions,
but in the end of the day,
these are the things that pretty much
all of the consulting
firms are looking for,
and if you address in
your experience interview
these types of dimensions,
you will be perfectly fine.
So what are typical
questions that will be asked
in these interviews?
Ang again, here they might
me difference firm by firm,
but usually the questions
are quite predictable.
You will be asked to talk
about an instance of your past
that you achieved something
that you are really proud of,
or you will be asked to
talk about a team conflict
that you had with another
person in the past,
and how you were able
to overcome the conflict
and what you actually did to solve it.
You might be asked about
any specific element
that you have on your
CV to provide a story
on how you really achieved an impact.
How you really made a
difference to the firm,
to the organization that
you were a member of
or that you were working for in your CV.
So these are the questions
that you should expect
and hear the first thing
for the preparation
is that these questions
should not surprise you
in the interview.
You should never put
yourself in a position
that in the interview it's the first time
that you are thinking about these things,
and on the spot, you need
to come up with a story
that happened in the past
that addresses the question
that you are asked.
If this happens, that you were
clearly not well prepared,
the likelihood is pretty high
that you will not be able
to just on the spot come up
with the best story to tell
in these instances,
therefore, what you absolutely need to do
as a preparation to these interviews,
that you at home, you think
about what stories could be
that would really address
these different elements
that we talked about.
Come up with at least five
stories that you could tell
to answer questions like that,
and prepare these stories.
Come up with a basic structure
about how you want to go
about telling these stories.
Think ahead what likely questions will be
that the interviewer will then
ask you about these stories,
because of course, again,
the interviewer will want to make sure
that you're just not making something up,
so he might ask some
very detailed questions
just to fact check you and to make sure
that what you are talking
about actually really happened.
So be well prepared.
Have these stories ready in your head,
so when an interviewer
asks you these questions
in an experience interview,
you already know what you
are going to talk about.
And we got in the experience interview
what I want to end with,
is that many, many people underestimate
is how important this
experience interview is.
For most consulting firms,
at least based on the
information that I have,
the experience interview
is easily as important
as the case studies,
but people in their preparation time
usually put the vast majority
into the case studies,
but only spend very
little time making sure
that they get the
experience interview right.
Don't be one of these people.
Make sure that you have your stories
ready and well prepared.
This way you will make a great impression
in your experience interviews
and then the experience interview
will be a success for you.
Now to the third section of this video,
and this is the case study interview.
The case study interview
is the most iconic part
of interviewing with consulting firms.
This is the type of interview
that is most specific to consulting.
Usually if you're
interviewing in a corporate
or even in a banking situation,
you do not have case studies,
at least in the number and
in the depth that you have
in a consulting interview.
Now for sure, I could
go into lots of detail
on the case study interview.
This alone would be material
for a whole new video.
Probably it would be material
for a multi hour course
to get ready for this
case study interview.
But in this video, I just want
to give you the highlights.
I just want to give you
the basic structure,
the basic things that you
need to have in your mind
when facing such an interview.
So what can you expect
when going into a case study interview?
The interviewer will often
pitch you a business problem
and talk about a challenging
business situation
that now you are supposed to solve,
that you are not supposed
to give your thinking,
your structuring on.
These business problems are often adapted
from actual projects that the interviewer
was working on in the past.
The purpose of all of this is of course
to now discuss with you issues
that you might very well face,
that you might very well experience
in your work as a consultant as well.
And of course,
now the firms are interested to see
whether you can handle these problems.
Whether you can come up
with some valuable insight,
some valuable structures that
would be actually helpful
in a real consulting project as well.
And one of the most important things
when you now face such a case study
is that you need to understand
what type of case study you are facing,
and hear that there are
probably at least two
important distinctions that
you need to understand.
The first is the whole
format of the case study,
and generally you can distinguish
two types of case study formats.
There's the interviewer-led
case study format
and the interviewee-led case study format.
So how do these two formats
distinguish themselves?
In the interviewer-led format,
the interviewer will lead
the whole conversation.
He will guide you through the case study
and he will go question by question.
He will present a little part
of such a more complex business problem,
and he will expect you to
now come up with an answer,
to come up with a solution to this part.
And once you have a bit of a discussion
about this specific part,
he might completely change the topic
to another aspect of this old case study,
and then he will go into the details
about this new part with you.
So this is now a format
where you are much more
on the receiving end.
You are not supposed to
now guide the interviewer
through his case study,
but it's rather you answering questions
that you will get on a
specific business problem.
This interviewer-led format
is famously used by McKinsey
as their go-to format in their interviews,
but of course many other consulting firms
use the interviewer-led format as well.
The interviewee-led
format is a bit different
in the sense that now
you as the interviewee,
now you as the candidate,
you are now into the driving
seat of this whole interview.
And what this means is that
usually at the beginning
the interviewer will give
you a bit of context,
a bit of a situation or they describe
the overall problem for you.
So for instance, he might
talk about a business.
Give you some specifics on that business,
and now will ask a rather open question
of what this business should
do to improve its profits.
But now you are in the
lead as a candidate.
You are in the lead as an interviewee.
Now the interviewer will
expect you to now ask questions
to the interviewer about
additional information
that you now want to have
in order now to come to a solution.
So here, now do not wait
that the interviewer
gives all of the relevant
information to you,
but you are now supposed to really ask,
to ask the interviewer all of the things
that you believe are relevant.
All of the things that you want to know
to now come to a conclusion.
The second key distinction
between different types of case studies
or maybe also between different question
within one case study
is whether this is rather
qualitative or quantitative answer
that you are now supposed to give.
So questions looking
for qualitative answers
are for instance, something like,
"Okay, please tell me
about the different aspects
"that are driving this problem," or,
"Tell me about the different ways,
"what a company can do to cut its costs."
These are questions that are
looking for qualitative answers
and with these qualitative questions,
what you are supposed
to do is not to just say
the first things that
come through your head,
but it's rather to come
up with a structure,
to propose this structure to
your interviewer as a solution.
These qualitative case study questions
you can look up lots and
lots of frameworks online
on how you can approach and solve
these different types of
qualitative questions.
He wants to see that
you are a structured guy
who can in a repeatable
way propose solutions
to complex business situations.
So in contrast to these
qualitative questions,
there are now also the
quantitative questions.
Here what you are supposed
to do are calculations.
If you are asked to come up
now with a certain number,
with a certain result.
Here you are now really
supposed to do some math,
to do some calculations.
What you should really do to practice
for these kind of interview questions
is to do math calculations both
in your head as mental math,
but also with pen and paper.
So practice to do complex
divisions or multiplications
with pen and paper without a calculator,
because in these interviews
you are usually not given a calculator.
So what can you do to really prepare well
for these case studies?
There's one thing that
I see many people do,
but I just do not believe
that it's really a good thing.
This is going online and
learning twenty, thirty, forty,
fifty types of different
frameworks, a ton,
just hoping that you will get
asked the exact same question
that now in this mock case
study online was asked
and then hoping that by
this you will come up
with the perfect answer.
This is usually not what
will help you to do well.
Yes, it's okay and also helpful
to have a couple of
frameworks in your head,
a couple of frameworks that
you can also easily tailor
to different types of questions,
and then this will help you to answer
especially the qualitative
types of interview questions,
but be reasonable and
don't do too much on that.
Instead, what you should do
is to do mock case studies
with other actual people.
What I did when I prepared
for case study interviews
back in the day,
when I interviewed with McKinsey,
is that I partnered up with another person
that was also interviewing
with MBB consulting firms
and we met once a week
or so and always prepared
about two case studies for each other
every session that we met.
And then we interviewed us.
We had such an interview,
and then we gave us
feedback on what went well,
what didn't went well,
and this for me really was super useful
for getting these case
study interviews right.
So how many case studies
should you do to feel ready?
Well probably three,
four, five is too little.
Probably 30, 40, 50 is just far too much.
You will just go crazy at some point.
What I would recommend you is to aim
for something like 10
to 20 mock case studies.
This should be completely fine
to get you used to the format
by doing ten plus mock interviews,
ideally also with different people,
you will build some confidence
that you can actually
master this interview type.
And this from my perspective
was the most important part.
So these are my suggestions
for the three most
important interview parts.
First, the CV review.
Second, the experience interview
and then the third, the
case study interview.
Now, if you want to learn even more
about how you can ace
the consulting interview,
have a look at the checklist
that I have prepared for you
for the really actionable to dos
that you need to get right
before you now sit in such an interview.
Again, you can find the download link
to this interview checklist
below in the video description.
Just enter your email below
and I will send you a link
to this preparation checklist
to help you get ready.
As always, if you are taking any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel.
Please also turn on the notification bell
by clicking on all videos,
because otherwise, YouTube
might not inform you
about all videos I release,
even though you are
already subscribed to me.
And last but not least,
if you want to see even more content,
also follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning.
Thank you so much for your time.
I really hope that this
added value to you,
that this helped you now to
master your next interview.
If you have any other questions,
just leave a comment below
in the comment section.
I will do my very best to
answer every single one.
Thank you for being here with me.
A good weekend to all of you.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.